Improvisation is a great tool for actors and
directors.
It improves morale on the set because it makes
the performers feel like they're a larger
part of the creative process as they try to
find lines that are better or funnier than
the screenplay.
But sometimes, a noble attempt at improv cracks
up the cast and leads to an unusable outtake.
For example ...
Anchorman
A laughter-free take of this scene made it
into the credits of this classic retro comedy,
including a line Will Ferrell apparently made
up on the spot, but that doesn't mean the
whole take was laughter-free.
It comes early in the movie, when Ron Burgundy
is conducting vocal warm-ups in the minutes
leading up to live news broadcast.
One is so ridiculous that even a pro like
Ferrell can't handle it ...
"The skeleton ran out of shampoo in the shower."
"The Human Torch could not get a bank loan."
"The Hu— "
"The Human Torch was denied a bank loan."
Anchorman 2
While filming the sequel to 2004's Anchorman,
writer-director Adam McKay threw out line
suggestions on-the-spot for young actor Judah
Nelson — one involving warm apple juice.The
kid gives it his all, but he can't quite get
through it …
"Can you yell, 'I don't want to drink hot
frothy horse p---?'"
"I don't wanna drink hor ... forthy …"
This is 40
Judd Apatow is a director that likes to feed
improvised lines to his actors.
While Billie Joe Armstrong of Green Day has
no problem playing punk rock in front of thousands
of rowdy fans, repeating one of Apatow's off-the-cuff
jokes while filming This is 40 made him lose
his composure.
Maybe it hit a little too close to home?
"Yeah, I'm really trying to get back in touch
with my anger."
"It's hard to stay angry when you're this
rich."
"It's hard to stay angry when — "
The 40-Year-Old Virgin
Some actors and directors work together so
often that they develop a rapport that results
in movie magic — real-life couple Leslie
Mann and Judd Apatow are definitely on that
list.
In this clip from the filming of The 40-Year-Old
Virgin, it's clear that Apatow treats Mann
like any other actor, providing on-the-spot
line suggestions to improve the scene.
Mann is game at first, but then breaks character
when Apatow crosses the line ...
"Do you wanna f--- in the car?"
"So, do you wanna f--- in the car?"
"No!"
"Do you like xtc?
Let's do some 'E' at my house."
"What?
Xtc?
Honey, we have kids!"
Trainwreck
LeBron James is obviously a great basketball
player, but who would've thought he'd be such
a charming and funny actor?
He holds his own as a thrifty, sensitive version
of himself in Trainwreck opposite formidable
comic talents like Amy Schumer and Bill Hader.
James rolls with all the improvised lines
fed to him, cracking up his co-stars …
"I had tortilla soup.
I can't get a hamburger.
Look at how big I am.
You think a tortilla soup is gonna last me
for the rest of the day?"
The Hangover
When your movie stars a veteran of The Office
and The Daily Show and a one-of-a-kind standup
comedian, it's best to just let them do their
thing.
In this scene from the first entry in the
Hangover trilogy, Ed Helms and Zach Galifianakis
engage in a rapidly escalating war of words,
reaching absurd, specific, and ridiculous
heights …
"You look like someone puked hair on your
chest."
face."
"Guys, did you see his body?"
"You look like you just swallowed two frozen
turkeys.
Happy Thanksgiving."
"What?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!